as someone who devotes hours to
discussing the deeper themes and
enriching undertones of anime it's
always been difficult for me to fully
evaluate a straightforward but genuine
romance or slice of life anime compared
to say a deep melancholic drama with its
subtle philosophical implications
and perhaps this is why it felt so
profound
when i would look up after every 20
minute episode of kagiasama love his war
with a beaming smile on my face
when i nearly cried laughing at
shivagani's attempts to dip his toes
into the world of hip-hop despite
everyone's pleas against it
when i felt such joy after witnessing
ishigami overcome his past trauma in one
of the most beautiful story arcs to be
written in anime when i felt like a
proud father seeing shivagane and kagia
finally submit in their long battle of
attrition and admit that they were in
love
[Music]
and perhaps it is for all of these same
reasons that everyone loves kagi osama
too
but it's a bit more than just that i
know
when i look at all these great parts of
kagiasama i see faint connections to
other great anime the show's
long-running dedication to gags most
notably this season's joke about
shiragon is rapping and the show's
commitment going so far as to include an
entire song and wrap piece to conclude
the arc reminded me a lot of the type of
humor i see in gintama
the short subdivided stories within each
episode done to respect each chapter of
course pave a path similar to the
disastrous life of psych ek capitalizing
on short bits to give the watcher a
comprehensive dive into every aspect of
our main cast's school life
the more connections like this that i
see
the more i am reminded of just how many
aspects of modern anime that kagiasama
has completely mastered in only its 37
episode run so far
but admittedly though i was always
certainly intrigued by the show it was
not until the end of season two reared
its head when i came to understand the
value of the anime i was watching of the
may i say
peak fiction
i was witnessing
once again perhaps it's because of the
way that i've grown to view anime and
how i naturally lean towards serious
shows but the part of kagiasama that
propelled it so high for me
was arguably its most serious part
the sports festival arc
and i feel like explaining this arc
alone first in this video can offer a
bit of insight into what i think makes
hagiasama special as a whole
this arc shows us ishigami's tragic
backstory amidst the backdrop of the
escapades of what should just be an
entertaining sports festival but what
more so acts as a plot device that
brings ishigami's growth as a character
it begins as his regretful decision to
join the cheer club and be surrounded by
peers the complete opposite of his
well disposition but through a series of
events it turns into a proud celebration
of ishigami's identity and confronting
the ghosts of his past
ishigami is like a lot of us i'm sure
a bit anti-social likes games with a
dash of pessimism and self-loathing to
top it all off but his story is stoic
and hard to watch frankly at some points
yet understandable
after beating up another student who was
mistreating his girlfriend to say the
least ishigami was told to write an
apology in order to return to school but
no matter what he did or how much his
teachers berated him he could not bring
himself to write something he did not
believe in
even if it means facing the scrutiny of
his classmates his teachers his parents
even kagi osama teaches us how difficult
it can be to stay true to ourselves and
remain unwavering like ishigami
but also
just how rewarding it can be
the finale to this arc was masterfully
done with shiragane and kagya saving
ishigami's lost soul and his spectacular
yet laughable admission to the girl he
saved long ago
the show rewards our faith in ishigami
for doing the right thing no matter what
punishment it brought and sticking
through to the end
and that ending is why we love him and
this storyline
or at least
why i do
and now i will pose the question what
about season three warranted kagyasama
to receive such high praise why does
everyone love it
well to be fair the first two seasons
were by no means low ranked it's also
often the case that the later seasons of
a good show are ranked higher than the
previous ones simply because a larger
percent of the viewers are the ones who
like the show enough to come back to it
but aside from those extraneous
logistics i believe the answer once
again lies in how the authors stayed
true to the characters and gave them the
perfect conclusion just like in the
sports festival arc
let's look at the defining component of
season 3 to further understand this
the cultural festival arc
the long-awaited dual confession
storyline in the cultural festival arc
was highly anticipated after all this
time
meaning that this finale was expected to
be nothing short of spectacular to begin
with
unlike the sports festival arc or any
arc that came before this one to be fair
this alone is the conclusion to
everything that's been built the main
premise of the story of kagya and
shiragane finally confessing to each
other
of course it's not the end of the series
but
that doesn't change the magnitude of the
confession that acts as a finale to the
entire high school story arc
nothing ruins a good show like a bad
conclusion
but nothing makes it better than a
magnificent one
if kagi osama tells us one thing after
it took three whole seasons of the show
before the main characters finally
admitted their love it tells us that
kagia and shirigane are unbending
neither will admit defeat but they will
also never stop trying
and without throwing this character
development out of the window the author
writes a conclusion in the dual
confession storyline where neither of
them actually confess to each other
shiragana asks if kagia will go to
stanford with him and she kisses him but
at the end of the long war between the
two it is only befitting and almost
poetic that neither of these incredibly
strong unbending characters ever
actually confess in the end
they can never admit defeat and outright
say it
we witnessed the ultimate display of
love from shiragane with every
last-ditch effort pulled out and
meticulously planned to make sure it all
went according to plan in a flourishing
finish to the season
one that stays truthful though to the
story it's built up to this point
it once again rewards fans for their
faith this time in khagia and shivagane
while also paying back to those of us
who believe that they as characters
would never be able to confess to each
other and made sure that they never had
to
through what i can only say is great
writing
following in the footsteps of and
expanding on what ishigami's story told
us in the season before kaguyasama once
again teaches us that it is important to
celebrate who you are and to never
change just because someone wants you to
it's human nature to stick to your guns
and even if you're lovesick or bullied
to be who you are
to be unwavering to be unbending
not only is it great writing but i think
that's a great reason alone for everyone
to love kagiasama
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to like and subscribe
for future in-depth show manga and
character analyses